el gobierno presenta hoy el esperado
anteproyecto de ley de memoria
democrática y es que tal y como han
señalado las naciones unidas- es una
anomalía que da todos los crímenes que
se produjeron durante el franquismo
españa todavía no haya alcanzado un
verdadero proceso de justicia y
reparación y a falta de conocer la
integridad del texto del anteproyecto de
ley sí que hemos podido conocer ya
algunos puntos de esta nueva legislación
por un lado la pretensión de ilegalizar
la fundación francisco franco y de
prohibir en general las exaltaciones al
franquismo también de profundizar entre
los más jóvenes en el conocimiento de lo
que supuso la represión franquista pero
hay dudas por ejemplo sobre el rol que
asumirá el estado en el proceso de
exhumación de los más de 100 mil
desaparecidos que se encuentran en fosas
comunes en todo el país unos trabajos
que hasta ahora asumían voluntarios de
distintas asociaciones como la de la
recuperación de la memoria histórica una
asociación que tomó la iniciativa en
2010 de llevar los crímenes del
franquismo a argentina donde se
investigan en base a la jurisdicción
universal y que plantean también otra
incógnita
qué eficacia tendrá finalmente la
fiscalía especial que pretende crear el
gobierno para investigar estos crímenes
ya que ahora estos procesos judiciales
chocaban con la ley de amnistía de 1977
una ley que no se pretende tampoco
abolir de hoy para mañana y finalmente
lamentan que no se pretenda crear una
oficina de atención a las víctimas del
franquismo y de que el texto de esta ley
tenga que ser debatido finalmente en el
parlamento con grupos de extrema derecha
como vox